♪ ♪
>> Juan: PRESIDENT TRUMP ONCE
AGAIN GOING AFTER THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION, THIS TIME
OVER ITS HANDLING OF THE
PANDEMIC.
TRUMP ACCUSING THE ORGANIZATION
OF BEING BIASED IN FAVOR OF
CHINA.
HE IS ALSO THREATENING TO CUT
OFF FUNDING PERMANENTLY TO THE
W.H.O. IF CHANGES ARE NOT MADE
IN 30 DAYS.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT EARLIER
TODAY.
>> BASICALLY THEY HAVE TO CLEAN
UP THEIR ACT.
THEY HAVE TO DO A BETTER JOB.
THEY HAVE TO BE MUCH MORE FAIR
TO OTHER COUNTRIES, INCLUDING
THE UNITED STATES, WHERE WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE INVOLVED WITH
THEM ANYMORE.
WE WILL DO IT A SEPARATE WAY.
>> Juan: DANA, I WANTED TO ASK
YOU, AS LONG AS THERE IS NO
TRAIN IN THE BACKGROUND, WHAT
HAPPENS IF THERE IS ANOTHER
UNKNOWN PATHOGEN AND I THINK
THAT’S LIKELY AT SOME POINT, IS
IT A GOOD IDEA FOR THE
UNITED STATES TO NOT BE A PLAYER
IN THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION?
>> Dana: I THINK THE PRESIDENT
IS DOING SOMETHING THAT HE’S
DONE BEFORE, LIKE HE DID WITH
NATO, WHICH IS USING AMERICA’S
INCREDIBLE AND EXTENSIVE
INFLUENCE TO FOREIGN EXCHANGE AT
AN ORGANIZATION IN ORDER TO HAVE
THE CREDIBILITY OF THE
UNITED STATES BE ABLE TO BE
THERE TO HELP YOU.
I THINK THAT WE ALL KNOW THAT
IT’S IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE
PUBLIC HEALTH INFORMATION IN A
WAY THAT WE CAN SHARE IT.
BUT OBVIOUSLY THERE WAS
SOMETHING EXTREMELY WRONG THAT
HAPPENED BETWEEN THE W.H.O. AND
CHINA’S COMMUNICATION AND THEIR
COMMUNICATION WITH THE WORLD.
I THINK GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF
THAT IS NUMBER ONE AND I DON’T
THINK THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING
THAT YOU WILL NEVER GET AMERICAN
SUPPORT AGAIN.
HE IS SAYING YOU HAVE 30 DAYS TO
COME UP WITH SOME SUBSTANTIAL
CHANGES AND THEN WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A PART OF IT.
IF YOU DON’T WANT TO DO THAT,
THAT’S FINE.
WE WILL WALK AWAY AND TRY
SOMETHING ELSE.
I THINK HE’S BEING SMART AND
FIGURING OUT A WAY TO LEVERAGE
THE UNITED STATES.
AS FOR CHINA, RECENTLY I THINK
IT WAS YESTERDAY SAID THAT THEY
WOULD DONATE $2 BILLION TO THE
EFFORTS TO HELP DEVELOPING
NATIONS AROUND THE WORLD.
$2 BILLION.
THAT IS 1/1000 OF WHAT WE’VE
ALREADY SPENT IN OUR OWN COUNTRY
TO DEAL WITH CORONAVIRUS.
THAT IS LIKE CHUMP CHANGE,
CHINA.
SO IF YOU WANT TO HAVE
INFLUENCE, YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE
TO PONY UP A LOT MORE THAN THAT,
STARTING WITH OPENING UP YOUR
LABS AND WHATEVER ELSE YOU HAVE
COME OTHER INFORMATION, TO GET
INFORMATION TO PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND AROUND THE
WORLD.
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE TO PROTECT
OURSELVES FROM THIS.
WE KNOW IT WILL HAPPEN AGAIN.
HISTORY DOES REPEAT ITSELF.
IT HAPPENED 100 YEARS AGO.
WE HAVE TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
FUTURE.
>> Juan: JUDGE PIRRO, I THINK
DANA’S RIGHT, THE PRESIDENT MAY
BE MAKING A STRATEGIC MOVE BUT
IT’S ALSO A POLITICAL MOVE IN
THE SENSE THAT I THINK HE’S
POINTING A FINGER AT CHINA FIVE
POINTING AT THE W.H.O.
SO POLITICALLY IT HAS POWER, BUT
IN TERMS OF POLICY, DO YOU THINK
IT’S A GOOD MOVE?
TO GIVE CHINA THE LEADERSHIP
POSITION AT THE W.H.O.?
>> Judge Jeanine: I THINK THAT
IS A BRILLIANT MOVE.
I THINK IT’S TIME THAT THE
W.H.O. CLEANED UP ITS ACT.
I THINK 316,000 DEAD PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD IS REASON
ENOUGH FOR AT LEAST 316,000
REASONS TO PULL AMERICAN MONEY
OUT OF AN ORGANIZATION THAT
COULD HAVE HELPED US AND COULD
HAVE PREVENTED MANY OF THESE
DEATHS.
THAT’S MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THIS ORGANIZATION SAID THERE WAS
NO HUMAN TO HUMAN TRANSMISSION.
THIS ORGANIZATION WAS BEING
LAUDED OR LAUDED CHINA FOR
INSTANCES WHERE THEY HAD TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS WITHIN THEIR OWN
COUNTRY.
THAT’S CRAZY.
DANA IS RIGHT.
WE HAVE TO LEVERAGE THIS LIKELY
LEVERAGE NATO.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO TAKE OUR
MONEY, PUT NOT ONLY THE
UNITED STATES WITH THE WORLD AT
RISK, IT’S TIME THAT IF THERE IS
MONEY, THERE IS TRUTH AND
TRANSPARENCY BEHIND IT.
WHAT TAIWAN CAME OUT AND SAID,
THERE WAS HUMAN TO HUMAN
TRANSMISSION AND CHINA SAID
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
WE SHOULD HAVE LISTENED TO THEM,
AND THE PRESIDENT DID.
SO THIS IS THE WAY HE HANDLED
IT.
>> Juan: JESSE, WHAT HAPPENS
IF THE NEXT PANDEMIC COMES OUT
OF AFRICA OR LATIN AMERICA?
WHO GIVES THE UNITED STATES THE
DATA, ADVICE ON HOW TO DEAL WITH
IT IF IT HITS OUR SHORES?
>> Jesse: HE SAID THAT HE
WANTS TO REFORM IT AND IF
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO BE
REFORMED, WE WILL FORM A NEW
ORGANIZATION.
YOU KNOW THAT, JUAN.
THIS IS WHAT I DON’T LIKE, HOW
THE MEDIA FRAMES IT.
I READ "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
TODAY IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
SAYS TRUMP IS DOING THIS TO
DEFLECT BLAME.
SO SEE WHAT THEY ARE DOING?
REPUBLICANS ARE ALWAYS
DEFLECTING BLAME.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE THE MEDIA IS ALWAYS
BLAMING REPUBLICANS FOR
EVERYTHING, RIGHT?
SO WHENEVER A REPUBLICAN DOES
ANYTHING THAT DOESN’T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE THING
THEY ARE BEING BLAMED FOR AT
THAT VERY MOMENT, THEY ARE
DEFLECTING BLAME.
SO BARACK OBAMA CAN GO AFTER
FOX.
HE CAN GO AFTER PUTIN.
HE CAN GO AFTER ISLAMAPHOBIA.
HE IS NEVER -- SHE’S NEVER
DEFLECTING BLAME.
ONLY REPUBLICANS DO THAT.
THEY DO THAT WITH THE WORD
DISTRACTION.
SO TRUMP IS DISTRACTING FROM THE
PANDEMIC BY GOING AFTER THE
W.H.O.
NO, ACTUALLY THE MEDIA WANTS
EVERYBODY TO FOCUS ON ONE THING
AND TRUMP IS JUST HOLDING
MULTIPLE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT’S THE GAME THEY PLAY.
>> Juan: IC.
GREG, YOU KNOW, IT SEEMS TO ME
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL,
THE CDC, HAS BEEN ASKING FOR
MORE MONEY.
SO YOU THINK THEY WANT A MORE
ROBUST INTERNATIONAL PRESENCE
FOR THEMSELVES.
DO YOU THINK MAYBE IF WE TAKE
MONEY AWAY FROM THE W.H.O. HE
WOULD GIVE IT TO THE CDC?
>> Greg: I DON’T KNOW, MAY BE.
THE CDC.
EVERYBODY WAS WRONG.
I THINK PART OF THE COMING
BATTLE IS GOING TO BE THE
EXPERTS WHO TOLD US WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE IN OUR BEST
INTEREST AND THEN THE REST OF
THE WORLD FOUND OUT THEY WEREN’T
TELLING THE TRUTH.
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT’S
BEEN SAID ABOUT NATO AND THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
AMERICA FIRST, I WAS CRITICAL
AND THOUGH I REALIZE THAT IT HAS
SOME BENEFITS.
IF YOU BELIEVE THE AMERICA FIRST
WAY, WHEN SOMEBODY SCREWS WITH
YOU, YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT THAT
GOES OUT THERE AND SETTLES THE
SCORE.
SO HE’S GOING TO SETTLE THE
SCORE WITH THE W.H.O. THE WAY HE
SETTLED THE SCORE WITH NATO AND
HE’S PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE TO
SETTLE THE SCORE WITH CHINA.
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS THEIR FAULT
WHEN THE VIRUS CAME OUT, THEY